JOHN HOPE BRYANT >> Do global businesses have
a code of ethics, or should businesses have
a code of ethics? Really funny, I thought
they always did or always should have. We
have confused a prosperity agenda with a money
agenda. What we have been doing has been a
money agenda. That's why it ran into a wall.
That's why it didn't work. Ah-a money agenda
is no agenda at all.
Ah-America's not everything, it's not even
most things. But it is a great example of
some things. It's a great example of what
one CEO of this century called "America's
special sauce." And that special sauce is,
I believe, the power of the idea. Ah-what
do I mean by that. Um-Ted Turner, the founder
of CNN, he didn't wake up in the morning and
said I want to be rich and powerful. Steve
Jobs, the founder-or the de facto founder-of
Apple and the innovator for-ah-iTunes and
the iPhone and iPod-he didn't wake up in the
morning and said I want to be rich and I want
to be powerful. Um-you know-Klaus Schwab,
the founder of the world economic forum, didn't
wake up in the morning and said ah-I want
to be rich ah-and I want to be powerful. And
you can go on and on with these examples.
Ah-the point is Bill Gates did not wake up
in the morning and said I want to be rich,
I want to be powerful. They said, "I have
an idea." Ah-I've got this idea and I'm passionate
about this idea and it's going to empower
people.
So you can empower people with twenty-four-hour
news or you can empower people with a better
way of living or-ah-it's going to serve and
help people help themselves in some significant
way and it caught on as a positive epidemic.
THey worked it because they were passionate
about this idea and as a result of it becoming
successful they became immensely-ah-wealthy
and powerful.
But you talk to these folks today, they're
still passionate about the idea. Klaus Schwab
thirty-five years after founding the water
_____ is passionate about the idea. We've
lost that. Yet, people who call themselves
entrepreneurs or call themselves CEOs who
took-takes a dollar bill or the rand or the
pound or whatever currency-the euro-and they
slice it up into pieces-ah-and call that entrepreneurship-that's
not entrepreneurship, that's not creating
value.
So should there be a business ethic? Um, of
course there should. If you don't have one,
you don't have a business. [LAUGH] Ah-you
have a slot machine-ah-but at some point-ah-that's
going to turn against you. So we really have
two choices. There's love and there's fear.
And what you don't love you fear. And the
reason that the world is all screwed up is
that most leaders today lead by fear. And
fear's first cousin is greed. Greed's best
friend is laziness and short-termism. Ah-and
all that feeds into this, "I want to get a
money agenda" that has slammed us into a global
economic wall.
So we need a hard reset. We need to get back
to the power of the idea. We need to get back
to a long view. Ah-we need to figure out how
to do well and do good and make capitalism
and free enterprise actually relevant to the
poor. Make capitalism and free enterprise
actually work for the poor. We need to spread
a movement of not just civil rights but silver
rights because if you don't have a bank account,
an understanding of money and free enterprise
and financial literacy in the twenty-first
century and the global economy, you are an
economic slave.
So if you didn't have the right to vote in
the twentieth century, in a-in a century of
democracy, you were a slave. If you don't
have an understanding of free enterprise and
capitalism-ah-in the system and the ability
to access it in the twenty-first century,
you're still an economic slave.
So we need to empower people with a-use this
crisis-rainbows after storms-this is business
ethics now-of empowering people so that you
have-treat your clients like relationships
and not as transactions. Ah-if every banker
had lent money-ah-to their borrowers-it was
their grandmother, you would probably wouldn't
be in this mess that we're in today. A global
call for a massive uptake of financial literacy
education and empowerment around the world
will-will create stability, will restore consumer
confidence, will allow us to have a business
that is sustainable and will help empower
people to be their own best-ah-advocate and
protector for their family.
You heard it here-ah-YouTube, at Davos. And
it's cold here but it's warm-ah-in this building
with all this energy and passion about trying
to make the world a better place. Rainbows
after storms.